>> Sean: WE WILL HAVE FULL
REACTION TO PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
SPEECH, A FULL-THROATED
ENDORSEMENT TONIGHT.
IT'S BEEN AN AMAZING RACE TO
WATCH, TWO THINGS THAT COME TO
MIND OF THE TOP OF MY HEAD, DO
YOU THINK JOE BIDEN CAN DO A
RALLY LIKE THAT?
I THINK IT'S IMPOSSIBLE AND I
DOUBT MANY PEOPLE WOULD EVEN
SHOW UP.
WHAT HAS BEEN AN AMAZING THING
ABOUT THIS RACE IT -- I SUPPORT
DR. OZ I'M VERY UPFRONT AND OPEN
BECAUSE HE'S IN AMERICA FIRST
CONSERVATIVE.
HE BELIEVES IN LOWER TAXES, LESS
BUREAUCRACY, HE BELIEVES IN
ENERGY INDEPENDENCE -- LOOK AT
THE STATE OF PENNSYLVANIA.
WE HAVE 200 PLUS YEARS OF
NATURAL GAS UNDER OUR FEET, HE
COULD BE SUPPLYING OUR NATO
ALLIES ARE WESTERN EUROPEAN
ALLIES.
DR. OZ HAS FACED TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS FROM
ESTABLISHMENT HACKS TURNING HIM
INTO SOMEBODY UNRECOGNIZABLE.
HE SUPPORTS SECURE BORDERS,
ENERGY INDEPENDENCE.
HE SUPPORTS LAW AND ORDER, HE
SUPPORTS SCHOOL CHOICE, HE
SUPPORTS CONSTITUTIONALISTS ON
THE BENCH.
HE IS A BELIEVER IN PEACE
THROUGH STRENGTH AND HE BELIEVES
IN FREE AND FAIR TRADE, I KNOW
BECAUSE I'VE KNOWN HIM.
ONE I ENDORSE THE DONALD TRUMP
VERY EARLY ON THERE ARE A LOT OF
PEOPLE THAT ATTACKED ME AND SAID
HANNITY, WHAT ABOUT
DONALD TRUMP, HE WAS ONCE
PRO-CHOICE, HE ONCE DONATED TO
DEMOCRATS, EVEN THE CLINTONS --
AND I WAS LIKE YEAH THAT WAS SO
HE COULD KEEP BUILDING BUILDINGS
IN NEW YORK, HE KNEW THE SYSTEM
AND HE PLAYED THE SYSTEM BECAUSE
IT WAS THE ONLY WAY TO GET HIS
WORKERS TO BE ABLE TO WORK.
HE ADMITTED IT WAS RIDICULOUS.
DR. OZ IS AN AMERICA FIRST MAKE
AMERICA GREAT AGAIN, SAVE
AMERICA CONSERVATIVE.
NOW THE PRESIDENT WITH A 55-0
RECORD OF ENDORSEMENTS IN A ROW,
THIS IS GOING TO BE AN
INTERESTING TO SEE THE IMPACT,
WE'LL HAVE FULL COVERAGE OF THE
PRESIDENT AND HIS RALLY BUT I
WANT TO TURN OUR ATTENTION BACK
TO THE WHITE HOUSE FIRST WHERE
JOE BIDEN HAS HAD A ROUGH COUPLE
OF DAYS -- TAKE A LOOK.
YOU DECIDE.
>> THANK YOU, APPRECIATE IT.
>> WHERE MY HEADING?
REALLY.
AFGHANISTAN, IRAN, IRAQ, NOW
UKRAINE.
THERE IT IS, EDUCATING PEOPLE IN
THE BACK.
>> SHE'S OVER HERE, HOW CAN YOU
MISS HER?
>> I TELL YOU WHAT -- THAT'S MY
GRANDDAUGHTER, MY OLDEST
DAUGHTER, ELDEST GRANDDAUGHTER.
>> AND HER FIANCE.
>> Sean: OBVIOUSLY HE IS NOT
DOING WELL AND DURING ONE LUCID
MOMENT, HE OPENLY REMINISCED
ABOUT THE GOOD OLD DAYS WHEN HE
ATE LUNCH WITH SEGREGATIONISTS.
YOU CAN'T MAKE THIS UP -- TAKE A
LOOK.
>> WE ALWAYS USED TO FIGHT LIKE
HELL, EVEN BACK IN THE OLD DAYS
WHEN WE HAD REAL SEGREGATIONISTS
AND ALL THOSE GUYS BUT AT LEAST
WE WOULD END UP EATING LUNCH
TOGETHER.
THINGS HAVE CHANGED, WE GOT TO
BRING IT BACK TO.
>> Sean: GOOD OLD DAYS, HAVING
LUNCH WITH SEGREGATIONISTS.
WOW, THAT'S THE SAME GUY THAT
PARTNERED WITH A FORMER KLANSMAN
ROBERT BYRD TO STOP THE
INTEGRATION OF PUBLIC SCHOOLS,
HE DIDN'T WANT PUBLIC SCHOOLS TO
BECOME RACIAL JUNGLES, THAT WAS
HIS WORD.
EVERY WEEK HE GETS WORSE AND
WORSE.
MAKE NO MISTAKE, JOE IS NOT IN
CHARGE.
HE BARELY KNOWS -- TODAY IS
FRIDAY, WHAT THEY OF THE WEEK IT
IS.
RADICAL SOCIALISTS HAVE TAKEN
CONTROL OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
AND FOR THE PAST YEAR THEY HAD
BEEN STEERING THIS COUNTRY OFF A
CLIFF FASTER THAN I ANTICIPATED.
I TOLD YOU IT WOULD BE BAD --
LIVE FREE OR DIE, AMERICA, THE
WORLD ON THE BRINK.
END OF THE MIDTERMS IN ORDER TO
DISTRACT FROM THEIR MANY
FAILURES, LIBERALS ARE NOW
ATTEMPTING TO GIN UP MASS
HYSTERIA AFTER SOMEONE LEAKED
JUSTICE ALITO'S DRAFT OPINION
THAT COULD SOON OVERTURN ROBY RY
WADE.
IN SPITE OF ALL THE HYPERBOLE
OUT THERE, LYING OUT THERE,
PROPAGANDA AND MISINFORMATION,
ABORTION IN AMERICA WILL STILL
BE LEGAL IN THE U.S. AND WILL BE
REGULATED BY STATE LEGISLATURES.
THIS IS WHAT WE SAID FOR A LONG
TIME.
IF YOU ARE A CONSERVATIVE AND
BELIEVE IN THE CONSTITUTION,
THEY MADE UP ENUMERATED RIGHTS
IN THE CONSTITUTION, THAT IS
SUPPOSED TO THEN GO TO THE
STATE, THAT IS THE TENTH
AMENDMENT.
ACCORDING TO PROMINENT DEMOCRATS
THE WORLD IS ENDING, THE SKY IS
FALLING, THE COUNTRY WILL NEVER
BE THE SAME.
>> THIS OPINION IS DARK, IT IS
INCREDIBLY DANGEROUS AND IT IS
NOT JUST ABOUT A WOMAN'S RIGHT
TO CHOOSE, IT IS ABOUT MUCH MORE
THAN THAT.
MANY AMERICANS SAY I'M NOT A
WOMAN IT DOESN'T AFFECT ME, I'M
NOT BLACK, IT DOESN'T AFFECT
ME -- ONCE YOU ALLOW THIS KIND
OF EXTREME POWER TO TAKE HOLD,
YOU HAVE NO IDEA WHO THEY WILL
COME FOR NEXT.
>> THIS IS A RADICAL, RIGHT
WING, RUNAWAY, REPUBLICAN
SANCTIONED ASSAULT BY THE
SUPREME COURT ON OUR FREEDOM,
OUR CONSTITUTION.
>> WE DON'T HAVE A LONG HISTORY
OF PROTECTING EQUAL MARRIAGE.
WE DON'T HAVE A HISTORY OF
PROTECTING INTERRACIAL MARRIAGE,
WE DON'T HAVE A LONG HISTORY OF
PROTECTING ACCESS TO
CONTRACEPTION.
ALL OF THOSE THINGS WE HAVE
COUNTED ON AND HE SAID THE
AMERICA WE ARE COULD POTENTIALLY
UNDER JUSTICE ALITO'S OWN
ANALYSIS GO OUT.
>> Sean: NOW WHAT'S THEIR
PLAN?
LET'S GO BACK TO COURT PACKING,
WE'LL TRY THAT.
NOT WHAT THEY'RE SAYING IS TRUE,
NOT ONE WORD.
THEIR RADICAL FOLLOWERS ARE
TAKING TO THE STREETS IN SOME
ARE ATTEMPTING TO HARASS
SUPREME COURT JUSTICES AT THEIR
HOMES.
ACTIVISTS POSTING A MAP ONLINE,
PUTTING OUT PERSONAL ADDRESS OF
SUPREME COURT JUSTICES, OTHERS
ARE OUTSIDE THE SUPREME COURT
BUILDING WHERE LAW ENFORCEMENT
NOW HAVE ERECTED A LARGE WALL
AND THOSE WORKING INSIDE FOR FAR
LEFT RIOTERS.
ONE LEFT-WING GROUP IS PLANNING
TO TARGET PRO-LIFE CATHOLIC
CHURCHES ON MOTHER'S DAY AND
JUST THIS WEEK A CHURCH IN
DENVER WAS VANDALIZED WITH A
PRO-ABORTION GRAFFITI.
LET ME BE CLEAR ON THIS PROGRAM,
WE CONDEMN ALL POLITICAL
VIOLENCE, ALL INTIMIDATION,
WE'VE GOT TO INCLUDE AND PROTECT
EVERY SINGLE ELECTED OFFICIAL,
EVERY JUDGE THAT SERVICE,
EVERYBODY THAT WORKS IN
GOVERNMENT NEEDS TO BE PROTECTED
AND FRANKLY EVERY AMERICAN
DESERVES LAW AND ORDER AND
SAFETY AND SECURITY BECAUSE
WITHOUT WHICH YOU CANNOT PURSUE
HAPPINESS.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM WITH DEFUND,
DISMANTLE, NO BAIL LAWS THE
DEMOCRATS HAVE SUPPORTED.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE WILLING TO
CONDEMN VIOLENCE ONLY WHEN IT
HELPS THEM POLITICALLY, NO ONE
IN THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS EVEN
WILLING TO CONDEMN THE DOXXING,
GIVING OUT THE ADDRESSES AND THE
HARASSMENT OF U.S. SUPREME COURT
JUSTICES.
THEIR SILENCE IS DEAFENING LIKE
IN THE SUMMER OF 2020, 574
RIOTS.
WE'VE HAD DOZENS OF DEAD
AMERICANS, THOUSANDS OF INJURED
POLICE OFFICERS, BILLIONS IN
PROPERTY DAMAGE, WHERE IS THAT
COMMITTEE?
LOOKING INTO THOSE RIOTS?
WHERE ARE THOSE PROSECUTIONS?
MANY DEMOCRATS HAILING THE
SUPREME COURT LEAKER AS A HERO.
IT'S ALMOST AS IF THEY WANTED
THESE JUSTICES TO FACE
INTIMIDATION.
DEMOCRATS ONLY CARE ABOUT POWER
AND THIS YEAR THERE IS NO WAY
THEY CAN RUN ON THEIR RECORD,
IT'S S